hello there it's been a while hasn't it
it's time for 69 more fortnite myths
like this the new Mythic item will
change the skin color of certain
characters okay let's try it
oh it is true it only works on a few
skins and I'm not unpacking that thank
you very much glitch King let's move on
is it possible to use the wrong
ceremonial dance and still pick up the
howler items around the map absolutely
not Leica gives you the thumbs down in
disapproval she wants you to use the
correct emote yet if you change quick
enough it is possible to completely
glitch it out Synergy without movement
next can the new Mythic save us from
Fall damage the leaping melee swing at
the top of the jump leads to well
imminent pain but should you time the
jump melee well enough it'll reset the
fall and you should land perfectly
without any damage at all and it also
works from Max height too Extra
Protection for those who skybase
we now have zombie chickens in the game
and I'm told that they can break builds
in one hit so I let those little
Cluckers pursue me and at first glance
it does look to be true but that was due
to the while still constructing the
zombie chicks will hit bills for 100
damage per pack nothing can stand in
their way except picking them up that's
their one weakness so does that mean a
zombie chicken can now win a fight with
a wolf not a chance right well it took
nine [ __ ] but officially zombie
chickens are not the bottom of the food
chain anymore when I win a chicken
dinner oh and can zombie chickens travel
through Chrome walls yes yes they can
the new NPCs and bosses around the
island during fortnite mares are our
main focus today over at Grim Gables a
summoning circle is waiting for a
sacrifice to activate it so we wondered
what could be used to awaken that demon
inside we threw a chick into the circle
nothing happened what about a bar or
wolf uh nothing at all not even a zombie
can activate the summon yet both the
friendly and enemy decoy Bots can
activate the boss fight so our attention
turned to neutral NPCs could they
activate the ritual rustler was the
closest so she shall be the chosen one
we blocked up all the Escape Routes and
fishing rodded her to the Drop Zone will
it activate holy heck yes it does so
next myth can wrestler defeat The
Inquisitor she tried then she ran a bit
then she tried again but ultimately she
was no match for the fiery demon
there must be someone on this island who
can fight The Inquisitor and I think
there is ash from the Evil Dead
franchise is now on the island for Fort
nightmares and his thing is vanquishing
the undead so we used fishing rods and
took our hero to the drop spot in he
fell and I was going to cut to a replay
file now but my game updated and my
replay files were corrupted so we had to
do it all over again this time we used a
vehicle and as long as someone was close
enough to Ash he'd stay on board so
attempt two let's do this ash fell into
the summoning site and immediately ran
away he bolted the second he heard the
scream and almost made it out before The
Inquisitor spawned in the two began
fighting with a huge rocket attack
against a single shotgun shell from far
too far away Ash continued running
taking the fight Outdoors followed by
that demon our Ash simply didn't want to
fight he wanted to run home and I've got
to admit the way he Dodges Rockets is
pretty impressive ultimately Ash did get
involved in the fight but it was too
little too late and he lost at long
range we finished the job for him but
The Inquisitor may be the strongest
person on the island I wonder if we
could get him to the herald okay so
ashy's performance Against The
Inquisitor was poor but worth a second
chance I think this time we took him
West to fight Willow an ax wielding boss
in another cabin we mastered the ash on
a truck technique and cornered him at
the house ready to fight meanwhile I was
bait to bring Willow into the same room
and once their eyes met Sparks flew
literally shotgun versus ax it came down
to this moment when each character had
one drop of Health left who do you think
won I'll give you five seconds to think
about it
foreign
he hits a huge blast with the shotgun
and immediately he heads back home
because he's a badass Ash has an
official record now of two fights one
win and one loss
enough fighting more flying to our usual
ritual every season we check if the new
NPCs and bosses have a glider which is
unique to them Ash default Willow
default Inquisitor default to this day
only Vader had a custom glider oh and
what about the zombies this year do they
have a glider so a quick test uh no no
they have nothing at all to stop them
flooding straight into the ground but
that also must mean they don't take fall
damage so new myth do zombies take fall
damage so I led this zombie up a ramp of
no return and then edited her fall yet
what the hell is this for some reason
they can float in midair this is weird
this is so weird anyway eventually I got
her to fall down she fell and she's
completely fine not to scratch on her
this leads to another test can zombies
touch water this year a very simple test
and no nope they cannot swim this year
and of course the Mystique tests now can
Mystique become the newcomers and on all
three occasions yes she certainly can
you can still try all the skin before
it's released in the shop and to finish
off mystique's tests can she become one
of the zombie heart I murderized one and
then attempted to take his skin and no
no it doesn't work rip something
unexpected did happen though during
these Mystique tests check this out what
the heck is going on here let me explain
how I got here so I became the The
Inquisitor and then a little after that
I went into one of the Chrome tornadoes
then after the skin ran out of time and
I reverted back to Mystique I was still
in the blob form which gave me floating
hair and eyes then once the blob is
complete Mystique is rebuilt but she
isn't rebuilt exactly as herself she
keeps the main framework of the
character she replaced look at her arms
and her shoulders they're still like Mr
Ink it's weird but that's where we do
things like this so weird what happens
when the Goo Gone shoots into the
slipstream well this is a quick one
nothing at all I really hoped it was
going to be like the saw blades and
they'd travel around without exploding
but no it's not to be oh but the
Halloween rocket launcher Shaw does work
it flies perfectly in the airstreams so
at least something went right today so
the Goo Gone has the ability to stick to
objects and the size of the goose sphere
around it depends on how much is pumped
into it so I asked a bunch of my Discord
to help me make the biggest goo pile
ever see scene and this is another
anti-climax to be honest the goo bubble
does grow but it stops at a certain
point so no world record here myth
busted to make ourselves feel better
about our wasted time we built this
Tower with goo fireworks it's completely
innocent nice architecture next can
Midas turn the new mythics gold or like
this it's busted sadly they remain their
OG color although there is a little
extra to this when they are taken out of
the inventory again the wolf mask
becomes gold so this is both confirmed
and busted at the same time by the way
here's all the weapons added this season
and surprisingly the Chrome weapons do
not become gold in midas's hands yet all
the others do the same thing goes for
shadow Midas the Chrome weapons cannot
be manipulated by him yet everything
else can except that new Mythic which
looks damn good in Gold come on we still
have a bunch of myths to get through is
it possible to stand on a launch pad and
not flung into the air well Birdo has
tried it and it's confirmed when wearing
the new Mythic use the jump ability just
before you land and you will stay
completely still breaking the laws of
physics wow but I also tried this on the
balloons that throw us up into the sky
and yet again using the howler claws we
can rewrite the rule book this might be
a good place to hide actually did you
know there's a red chest on the island
get your butt over to the Rave cave and
by the side exit is this it looks like
just a lighting issue but damn that does
look like a red chest to me and finally
a really serious one now what happens if
you don't thank the bus driver I'll try
it what's the worst that could happen
[Music]
thank you